where there's minimal risk involved
magnus
let's see what he opens with
okay one knight f3 very solid start one
of my favorite moves the reti opening
very flexible as well so
not
too
adventurous here from magnus yet
what will we see him play next that's
the biggest one
magnus is not going to do that he he
doesn't tend to experiment during this
critical
rounds and uh here he's playing
something very very normal wow it's a
ronin though who's experimenting
auronian nearly never plays the king's
indian defense
um i've only seen him play kind of
variants of the king of the king's
indian if he's in muscle in situations
which he is now but is this going to be
i was going to say is he going to
capture the pawn because he just needs a
draw
capturing the pawn is a very good choice
if you only need to draw because the
main line that black can play is a
perpetual yeah so there are other moves
that black can do though to keep the
game going but capturing the pawn it's
the obvious choice i thought lev might
might go knight bd7 instead right to
avoid this
but he doesn't he doesn't okay wow you
saw lev there just kind of holding his
breath hoping that magnus wouldn't go
for a drawing line
his stuff is great so yeah i suspect
that magnus does know though and he's
just simply deciding what to do
and
i'm surprised at this choice because
yeah you know i'm sure computers will
love it and it does take space in the
center but on the other hand play gets
so sharp
um i wasn't expecting that i expected a
much more
flexible move such as uh moving the rock
or maybe developing the bishop committal
stuff from the world champion make
negative decisions but this one is
extremely risky
um this one is going to be a
full-blooded fight
i mean aronia must be really happy
white's pawns if we look at the central
two at least um they do point in the
other direction uh so that's the side
white normally wants to play on but
meanwhile
i think i've actually seen this as well
this pawn sacrifice he gets his desire
for fighting chess
and
trade off bishops
black's rook now kicks away the white
queen and defending is just a very
uncomfortable thing to do
and well magnus steps back
to the square that david highlighted
earlier and
now the big question is whether levon
will actually use the plan that david
suggested of just shifting the queen and
attacking that uh white queen with his
work
oh i thought he was going to go for it
i was about to say there's another way
you could do it you could start
attacking the white queen with your
knight instead by pushing the pawn
forward the second one was actually to
step forward with the knight
okay that didn't work
stepping forward with the night maybe um
i guess you want to back it up by
pushing the pawn forward and supporting
this knight it's definitely possible
magnus chose a slightly different
approach maybe he can still do this he
pushed his pawn forward i guess at least
last resort you can hide back with your
queen if you really really need to two
bishops idea king queen bishops i think
you could be tattoo brothers kind of
websites online of course you have to
download watch your uh kind of check out
your opponent's past games but uh going
to g7 so uh big threat now of coming to
attack the white queen just staring down
the camera there kind of breaking the
fourth wall uh and then
it looked like he didn't even put his
hand on the mouse but her move appeared
oh and uh he brought his knight forward
and that's why we're just so happy to be
to be here and be a partner but uh i've
been trying to i've been following what
has been happening online now as well
i'm watching all the memes going along
it's just like well i think chess you
know we do a lot of sponsorships in the
sports space but chess in particular
chess players are always learning about
technology like they're learning how to
get better at things right in a new
technology cryptocurrency and also stock
trading in the united states you know we
we think it's like a very unique way a
unique subset of people that are going
to be very
willing to embrace new technology
absolutely like that's why we're we've
had a crypto cup last year um we did our
first one and that was the online
tournament this time we're doing it live
in miami we're planning already for next
year and what's to come and yeah we
think we can keep the whole thing going
for for a long time what's happening on
the board some massive developments kaia
and we have to jump straight in uh we
have to show what's been happening
because magnus the world champion has
given up his queen uh we left the
position around here white's queen was
in big danger but uh here levon ironian
i have a feeling he should have pushed
his pawn forward to stop what magnus has
just done instead black jumped
in with his knight threatening to trap
this white queen and uh magnus just
didn't care he pushed his pawn forward
and after an exchange uh here he allowed
a double check a discover check all
sorts of ideas now uh along this line
magnus did once say to me that he loves
allowing discover checks because they're
so uh counterintuitive here the black
knight jumped forward white's king hid
in the corner and uh we got to catch up
with the moves but the white queen now
under fire it didn't even move magnus
gave up his queen just by capturing the
black knight in the center and after the
queen fell suddenly he took back and a
big threat on the board the white rook
just wants to slide across and pin
the black queen regaining the material
with interest and levon moved his queen
out the way and the knight drops back
and
just a couple more moves have been made
and here levon is fighting on the other
side of the board the current material
is a queen for a rook and a knight and
white has a pawn so it's actually level
material but it's more about the fact
the white has so many pieces the volume
of white's pieces and what a move this
one is pushing a pawn forward
yeah i mean the knight the bishop the
rook they look dominant the rook's
coming in soon
what's the idea behind this one though
if black just takes this pawn off
is he just trying to keep the position
closed and bring his rook in or
something i mean that's the only thing i
can think of trying to deny black any
open files for his rook on the other
side of the board and keep control um
well i mean in the end aronia decided
not to do that but uh
the question now in my eyes is can can
you shut that bishop down and
just keep black's pieces out of the game
i mean this move looks so obvious
to play i guess the knight is maybe
hanging on the edge of the board yep um
but you're right simon i mean if you can
get this move in if you can lock down
this black bishop it's at some point
super strong and i think we saw it just
flash up on the screen temporarily but
white white's best move um was the white
knight jumping back at least according
to stockfish and uh yeah it looks like
this is a monster threat now simon uh
the one you mentioned if black for
example takes a time out
okay he does stop this but then this
bishop would be kicked back to its
starting square the bishop terrible
piece just like we've seen earlier today
in some games the rook blocked in as
well and uh the problem is for black
there's an attack brewing against his
king
he's been fired beautiful stuff this is
i mean every move is just flowing by
magnus he's barely pausing
you're like okay he understood
instinctively like he didn't even bat an
eyelid he just gave up his queen for the
rook and night and it's just like right
my time now it did have a downside and
that was his king safety yeah like if if
there were pawns around the king we
would not be sat there going wow what a
wonderful position what has
a different path
as simon points out and remember if we
see a checkmate on the board we have
promised our viewers a checkmate dance
so it's just it's an easy one to
remember right so you could just do that
all night
there you are where simon in this day
and age that people can clip that
no don't don't clip it please
that's enough
david what's going on in the game please
say about this what is going on with the
bar yeah the evaluation bar is not happy
with this bishop trade that magnus has
just gone for
um suddenly the black rook i was
complaining about in the corner it has
woken up it has joined the battle
i mean to me it looks like checkmate
still
instead of the knight coming in sort of
knight f7 after pawn takes i mean just
uh you have to calculate that as well
and he's gone for night jesus
okay so he okay you're right simon maybe
this is one idea for white threatening
to come across and deliver checkmate
still mightily complicated but instead
he did jump with the knight and okay
magnus didn't go this way he went the
other way
does this give black any chances
it is a double attack you're hitting the
queen and you're hitting this knight
but where can the queen run to but you
have to save the black queen the queen
has actually moved to the h4 squad well
i was thinking rook h3 is nearly is it
i was like
rook rook h3 is like my first fault but
i haven't calculated it i had to take
away the rook and after the black queen
is distracted knight f6 is the idea and
uh trying to get some
because perpetually
yeah exactly that's why i was thinking
by i don't know this kind of stuff was
still super complicated super
complicated black king goes into the
corner do you yeah
yeah maybe you can take this one uh with
your rook and checkmate is coming and
we have those big things going on yeah
massive things okay we have to go back
to the players now because we're about
to see a draw we will explain this later
and uh we are about to see a draw by
perpetual check
massive drama magnus uh was a bit about
to take under the minute the bar going
back and forth he only needs a draw
and it is going to be a draw nothing
else to do and magnus clinches it what a
game and did we see a handshake but it
is a match loss for lavon aronian losing
one game